all right the footwork now we're going
to do a ipti syu all right so the
footwork couple things to understand is
we don't want to be double weighted and
so I'll Define what double weighted
means uh we don't want our Center
gravity
between the elements of our basis
support okay so right now I'm in the
horse stance
and the elements of my basic support are
my two
feet I don't want my center of gravity
sitting in the middle of it ining those
things okay so in application I would
always move my center of gravity over to
one Bas of support such that this foot
it doesn't have weight on it in terms of
for example the boat rowing exercise
really what is important to understand
like a lot of times people are just
doing this stuff and then they have
uh Stupid applications all the time this
is very much common in iido so let's see
I I'm doing these rolling exercises do
you see and then uh people go and then I
do my
technique so I'm going to
Row in
here here and then and somehow there
like oh it's magic Presto because and
it's so awesome because I did it from
here you see the same thing in the sword
work so people go it's like the sword
and then U they'll bring out the sword
and then everyone goes oh and then it
works you know it's was like but was the
sword valid was the sword work valid do
you get what I'm saying so I'm you're
going to go here and here and then they
go oh see if he grabs me I here and
here and then he goes like the sword
every okay all right so same thing you
have these rowing exercises they've made
their way in iido throughout history but
they're not being done correctly Okay so
first thing we said was I don't want to
ever be double weighted all right and
then I gave you an example that I would
have my line of gry over here such that
this foot actually has no weight on it
even though it's touching the ground
it's mobile I can slide it around if I
have my weight here or here's my line of
gravity I can't actually slide it it
gets kind of stuck on there okay all
right um
actually so
somewhere in there as I'm trying not to
double weight I'm have to shift my
weight and somewhere in shifting my
weight I have to bend my knees okay and
the way it works is that my knee my knee
is actually governed by my ankle so my
ankle can only either be
straight you see
and to have my ankle straight I have to
bend my knee you see
that and my knee at
Max can't go past my toes do you see
that so if I go over here like this my
center of gravity is over here in front
of my foot I want to fall forward okay
so when you do the bow rowing
exercise you're actually taking your
ankle from
straight to toes now do it on the back
leg Dave all right straight to toes you
see that
home so what I'm doing is as I go knee
to toes here at knees to toes I'm
actually on this leg I'm on this leg
this leg can slide and when I come back
to here I'm on that leg and this leg can
slide
okay so for nomenclature I would say
when the ankle is straight the front leg
is in Yin when the knee is at the toes
the front leg is in yangong okay so same
thing
yangong put it in Yin the other one's in
Yang and here is your boat exercise
okay
now let's
turn or let's go straight let's go
straight so when I want to do a
yumii I'm going to put this leg from the
yin phase into the Yang phase now all
weight is on that leg and then I move
forward take this
knee put it in it Yin face and now my
knee is in the y face here and this is
how I'm
moving
boom boom and I'll show you
why if he is resisting me he's pushing
me and I try to walk right now my Center
gravity is in the middle and I try to
walk I can't go forward okay he
interrupts my attempt to go forward
because my Center gravity will just come
off of the bracing angle of the back leg
and be pushed right back onto it so
instead I have to bring this into a Yin
face and he's pushing and really what
I'm doing is I'm now grounding on that
leg then I can move forward okay you
guys understand that is it clear is it
clear okay now I want to turn so in
order to go straight I have to do this
Yin and on with my knee angle and my
ankle Angle now I'm going to turn Okay
so to turn it's going to be the same
thing I don't want to double pivot
because now I'm double weighted so I
never double pivot never double PIV okay
I always am going to bring one leg into
the Yang phase and then
turn on that leg so I would bring
weight here and this this foot is now
free to move the weight is here and then
I turn and I single pivot okay so let's
say for
example we're doing Tio
handup okay I'm not going to go
here and then turn with my weight
between my
legs I will
enter shift my weight onto the one
leg and pivot on that leg this step back
has no rotation in
it so I go
one shift my weight onto that leg that
means put my knee in the Y phase knee to
toe and then double and then single
pivot there's no weight on here there's
no rotation on the step back so I'll
show it a little bit more Dynamic it
come come
around enter dude get your
grip Boom turn
St boom enter shift turn single pivot
step
B go pivot
turn
get
[Music]
it
all that's TR in sh nag I'm sorry shho
gidy we have to put this footwork into
play so as I slide the front foot
forward I don't want to go here my
weight is on the back foot I slide side
forward to turn I bring my knee to the
Yang face single pivot and then that
foot goes
forward bring it to the Yar face single
pivot weight goes forward bring the knee
to the Yar face turn and you didn't turn
Okay so that's what we were doing here I
cut one I'm on that right foot when I
come back I'm going to be on the left
foot when I go in I'm on the right foot
when I come back I'm never going one two
four okay when it comes to the a count
sity the first move first thing the form
is way too long it's too many steps to
actually
do uh internal
work it's too long so I would always
divide it up in either two moves moves
max four moves okay so maybe we'll do
four maybe we'll stop at two but I just
want to show how this is always the same
so in the first count I had to shift my
weight to the back foot pivot on that
back foot and you have aido 10 coming so
I'm here shift my weight boom and the
cut you're on the left make sure
you're not so twisted up you can't be
twisted up like this it's too much
angle so shift turn
cut straight down your
Center
here too
much it's because you're on the left
foot so up
turn cut
realign shift shift your weight onto
that front foot boom and then you can
come in with the ski to turn around
shift your weight onto this
foot so that foot comes back and then
cut shifting your
weight cut then you have the other side
bring your right knee to the Y face over
here taking weight off of the that
foot up cut same thing keep it in the Y
phase forward you go on the
ski bring the knee to the Y phase
turning on the cut boom so I'm doing
these y phase back leg single pivot cut
don't cross yourself young
Face
ski y face
turn cut repeat young face
turn cut y face inter ski y
face young face rotate single
pivot
cut
okay let's
try so let's focus on the on the line
okay so as I come back I'm going to turn
that's when that knee goes into the Yang
phase okay so it turn up is where I have
it so there's no step here okay so if
you look I have an angle because I had
ushido ten Kong clearing the line of
attack the cut is on an angle don't make
it over here here is where the subi
training is Bo straight on my Center
okay when you come forward on the
ski don't have your ski already turning
you see how I'm twisted again okay the
ski comes straight so from here it's
here and you're straight okay and then
my hips are square my foot is square
then I turn
okay you can either step out if you
want if you're going to take another
step it's one two on the cut if you
don't take the step it's just boom on
the cut but the foot still hits first
foot and then sore if it's on the
two-step foot back step H is where you
cut same thing don't get all twisted up
like this here's where your Center is
doesn't matter if I have an angle on the
weapon so
around up boom down in boom ski turning
stepping boom on the Second Step okay
watch how much because when you take the
second step your hips going to turn some
so watch how twisted up you get that is
not going to work all right let's try
to
okay so when if you watch my knees get
where you need to be in okay so when I
go back this knee is going to go to that
Yang phase you see okay but when I
finish that maneuver the ankle is
straight you see that so when I do the
aashi forward then it has to go back
into that okay other otherwise when I
try to step I would be pushed okay so
you have your just hold it however you
want sure whatever okay so to go forward
and you'd be over here a little bit
let's kind of game it because I know
where I'm going to go okay you're just
an oncoming resistance so I have to
shift and now that foot can work you get
it okay so uh go ahead so I'm here like
this I shift now that foot can work boom
pop and my body can go forward okay you
got it all right so I would let's see if
you could hold it up by your don't put
it on your throat just CU I'm going to
come up with it you see okay so let's
say we got to kind of gain this I want
you over here okay when it comes time to
do the
ski and your you're grounding here this
is your cou projection okay don't let it
hit you in the in the throat okay I
won't do it hard so when I
ground
in is what you want okay now if you
start turning your body so let's say you
double weight Center Line I would never
get there okay but if I not going to get
there let's say you did somehow and
you're you're like this because you're
ready to turn you didn't do this
maneuver okay ski maybe from here on
you is straight
boom hips square foot square this is
another movement got it so when you go
into ski don't get ready to
turn don't turn your hip don't turn your
foot don't turn your head that's another
movement so from the left side I would
go up boom it's here boom in straight
you see and you would carry that over so
I would go straight and then the turn
you see how I did that make sure you're
not ski and still or still in ski and
already a quarter way into the turn okay
try to so at the end of each count of
the suity you always have the ski and
the turn
and then the cut okay so that part's the
same but what is also always the same is
you're going from the yin phase ankle
straight to the Yang phase whether
you're going forward or whether you're
turning you have to do that so that you
don't double weight or double pivot or
have your line of gravity between your
two elements of your basic support okay
so for example uh obvious one uh would
be a yashi count to shift to the Y phase
and you come in on your ski and then
this part will be exactly the same you
guys got it okay then you're going to do
ten con the Tenon version so again shift
to the Y face so you can double PIV so
you can single pivot and this part just
goes straight back and then you repeat
what you were doing before or the ishido
Tenon so you're going to do the Shido
tankcon you're going to shift onto the
front foot so that you you can turn and
then you're going to go forward shift
onto the front foot again so you can
turn to do the cut and you have the ski
and then you have the second cut okay it
doesn't matter what you're doing it ten
con we already did ten con that was
actually count two a yashi and then the
10 con version um it it does not matter
what you're going to do in this form you
are still going to use your knees and
your ankles in this particular way to
avoid what we said
so if you're doing your Technique like
we lately we did uh standing we did uh s
okay so when he pushed I grounded on the
back foot I moved onto the front foot
I'm on that front foot in the Yang phase
right that's where I can drive out then
I shift to the Yang phase on this knee
that's where I can push boom okay so
I'll do it again I'll do it on the same
side so single pivot move single pivot
move single pivot
R I'll say left to describe the Y okay y
means need to toes so
left
right left in then I can
move or we're doing if C nugget right uh
so I'm going to go backwards in this
variation so shift
[Music]
move if you want to shuffle you'll shift
you
see
shift enter shift again to turn enter
again
I'm constantly doing the boat
exercise but understanding it giving
myself a metric straight angle Yin knee
to toe y get out from your Center Line
being on your line of gravity being in
the middle of your basic support
elements
okay